peace
[Music]
[Applause]
how you doing people
oh lordy lordy did you catch the little
cameo in the cold open right there if
you didn't we're gonna throw to it in
just a second once again
i'm dave rubin this is the reuben report
direct message it is april 8th 2022 we
are live streaming on rumble and on
blaze and on youtube subscribe if you
have not already we got a whole bunch to
get to today i'm in a good mood on this
friday it was miami mike my producer's
birthday last night we went out in
miami
and yet we all came to work today
because we are a professional
organization over here at the reuben
report let's throw back to that cold
open because i don't know if everybody
saw what i saw this is at a university
of buffalo allen west event alan's a
good buddy of mine and a great american
spider-man
just chillin
on the stairs at this university of
buffalo thing so alan west of course you
guys know alan west i've had him on the
show a couple times colonel allen west
he is a truly a great great american
like an american hero this is a
wonderful
spectacular patriot uh he was trying to
give a talk at the university of buffalo
suny buffalo state university in new
york at buffalo i went to state
university of new york at binghamton in
new york my brother
actually went to suny buffalo is
spider-man my brother
possibly i guess it's as possible as
anything else but here are these lunatic
lefty
woke
whack-a-doodles
you know i don't say violently but they
are basically forcing the issue here
they are making sure that this guy
cannot talk peacefully they are using
their free speech to infringe on someone
else's free speech which you're not
allowed to but one more time i just want
to see because the way that spider-man
is just sitting there even spider-man is
like
like sandman fine green goblin fine
these people just let them be let them
be it's just anyway i just thought that
was just like a perfect way
to start the show uh guys if you have
not heard i have a book coming out in
four days okay four days that's less
than 100 hours from now don't burn this
country i've started some of the press
much of it will be uh leaking out over
the next couple days but the book comes
out on tuesday daverubin.com book if you
order it now you can get your book on
tuesday it's good i promise you and i
did read the audiobook myself it's funny
it's light it's enjoyable you can listen
to it on the train or on the plane or
when you're sitting or when you're
walking or whatever else you might do
and i'm going on tour
we got a big tour coming i will be with
don jr in west palm beach on april 19th
that's the first show then benny johnson
in clearwater andrew clavin in raleigh
north carolina michael males in atlanta
janmi park in chicago glenn beck and
dallas megan mccain in d.c megan kelly
in west nyack dennis prager and brea
larry elder in oxen are douglas murray
in san jose blake masters in phoenix
brian callan in denver dave rubin.com
events there are a couple vip tickets
left i think at each show we expanded
them because all the vip seats sold out
real quick for the meet and greet and
the one second hug in the whole shebang
uh so we did add some so i think there
are some left over so i hope to see you
guys out there and just to be very clear
the dc show which was canceled has been
uncancelled uh the venue uh i believe is
it the majestic theater or the miracle
theater in dc what is it what get me the
name on a theater it's either the
majestic or the miracle theater miracle
it's the miracle theater well a miracle
happened they originally had told us
there would be no
uh vaccine passport no testing
requirements masks any of that so we
booked the room then of course they said
there would be the requirements we
cancelled it and then because we pushed
and pushed and pushed they back down and
the show in dc is odd okay let's get to
the show today
as i said i'm psyched i'm in a good mood
i'm ready to roll uh we're gonna just
basically do a weekly recap of just
the general state of lunacy that just
does not seem to stop coming and it
ain't gonna stop coming and let me just
do one last little promo here this book
has some of the ways that you can push
against it i've been hinting at a lot of
the ways here on the the dave rubin
program and i think
that uh some of the other ways i've left
them in the pages of that book so yeah
we're going to get into the week that
was just the the left and the wokesters
they just keep coming but we're pushing
back we're fighting okay fine so let's
start at the border we've got a problem
on the southern border we're not talking
about it that much right now actually if
you're paying attention to the corporate
press which of course lies about
everything or doesn't cover stories they
don't want to cover there hasn't been a
tremendous amount about what's going on
on the texas border for the most part
but it's arizona too there's some other
places where there's all these border
people coming in and they get into other
states and everything else okay fine
um so you're not seeing it so much in
the mainstream media but there are some
media outlets mostly fox news from a
mainstream perspective that are covering
what's going on down there right now so
we've got a quote here from fox news a
border patrol chief raul ortiz predicted
the u.s will reach 1 million migrant
encounters at the southern border for
this fiscal year any day now which would
likely indicate an outpacing of last
year's over
1.7 million the heritage foundation
president dr kevin roberts is sounding
the alarm on the border crisis warning
the migrant surge is upending the
american way of life as border agents
grapple with strained resources and
staff shortages when you visit the
border as i've done many times and you
talk to mayors and county officials but
most of all regular americans you
realize that this surge is upending the
american way of life this is not a
democrat or republican problem he
continued it's run by a biden harris
regime that actually wants illegal
immigration to happen to upend our
american way of life dr roberts stated
we have to get to a fair transparent
immigration system that honors the rule
of law okay so let's start with the
basics the 101 stuff having a border
whether it is a wall or it is electronic
or it is a moat
or there's robots there and alligators
and a whole bunch of other stuff is not
racist every country exists to say hey
this is our land these are the rules we
have in our land our land is for our
people
that's it there there is nothing racist
about that period that's number one
number two if you don't defend your
border if you just say hey people can
just kind of wander on through and then
we might give them a bunch of stuff
we'll get to that in just a second then
in essence you don't have a country you
just have sort of an amorphous blob that
can kind of exist and not exist and
doesn't really have any rules and i
guess that's sort of at some level what
the democrats really do want us to have
here
that's number one number two um
it seems to me that this administration
is intentionally doing this right they
they sort of tell people to come then
they kind of tell them not to come but
then they give them
money and gifts and transportation and a
whole bunch of other stuff and if you
don't believe me
well occasionally they tell people they
realize how bad it's getting and then
they tell people not to come even though
every other message is that they should
come here's jensahi actually saying
something sane and we will continue to
take additional steps to implement um
and make clear
that this is not the time to come
god is that the first time on the show
is that it that that i got two thumbs up
over there this might be it
zaki actually said something sane i
should have had some sort of little
thing that i could have you know like i
cracked a bottle of champagne or
something that was extraordinary but the
reason she's saying don't come right now
is because of those numbers that i just
read this million already as we're only
in you know the fourth month the
beginning of the fourth month of the
year the numbers are out of control and
even the democrats who have let this all
happen and tried to desperately stop
orange man from doing something about it
even they're realizing we got a problem
on our hands but the press conference
continued and then saki went back into
her her usual nonsensical lying or
obfuscating the truth self uh here she
is uh talking to peter ducey about uh
stuff that were given the illegal people
why would you give illegal people stuff
am i too old school i don't really get
it first on immigration our team in
texas is
saying that you guys are starting to
give smart phones to border crossers
hoping that they'll use the phones to
check in or
to be tracked i which part of that is
supposed to deter people from crossing
illegally into the states well i think
you of all people since you've asked me
a range of questions on this topic over
time would recognize that we need to
take steps to ensure that we know where
individuals are and we can track and we
can check in with them
so we give people people come here
illegally they have no right to be here
now i'm for legal immigration having a
process if you'd like to come here we
can discuss what that number is we could
discuss whether you have to have family
here or a place to stay here or what
your skills are do we need those skills
that labor etc etc we are a nation of
immigrants all of my great grandparents
and i think on one side one great
grandfather first generation immigrants
all came here american dream same as
your family okay pretty good uh but you
can't just walk in
and then you get stuff
you get a phone
and they give you the phone and then
ducey asks a perfectly legitimate
question uh you know people might toss
that phone away or not like are they
tracking she almost implied that they
actually track people with these phones
which would be sort of like you know
tracking cattle which i don't even know
if that would be considered legal or not
or if that's ethical or not i mean if
people are here illegally and you want
to track them that actually sort of
seems right to me i don't know there's
some there's some legal and i would say
philosophical ethical issues around that
but yeah we give people phones and we
know that we also give them money and we
know that we bus them all over the
country and everything else ron desantis
here in florida by the way if they try
to put any of these people in florida
he's bussing them to delaware which is
just absolutely spectacular but you know
we've had very mixed messaging on uh
whether people should come because
everything the democrats do is telling
people to come and then suddenly they
say do not come and you may remember we
put this one together shout out to
connor
this is not the time to come do not come
do not come
i'm gonna come
[Applause]
that's some fine work there connor
you're getting the guacamole today
internet we love you internet uh all
right you got the point there there's
some immigration problems here and the
mixed messaging is allowing people to
comment whether we're giving them phones
or not and what are we doing with them
etc etc it's all completely bananas but
okay let's move past immigration because
the big thing lately is whether boys or
girls and girls are boys that really is
the number one
issue in america so let's go now to sake
and basically yeah the government pretty
much wants to pay for these procedures
every major medical association agrees
that gender affirming health care for
transgender kids is a best practice and
potentially life-saving
okay first off i'm not exactly sure that
that true that every major medical
situation is telling you that gender
affirming surgery is best practice and
potentially life-saving if if you're a
little confused about this stuff and
what's happening to young girls who want
to transition to boys specifically you
should check out my interview with
abigail schreier she wrote an
extraordinary book about this and there
is all sorts of conflicting medical
information about this and their bodies
are changing and this has nothing to do
with hating trans people and it has
nothing to do with not wanting adults to
live the way that they live but then she
says it's potentially life-saving and
it's like and then you couple this with
all of the other nonsense all of the
other nonsense that we've been talking
about with bill hb1557 better known
unfortunately as the don't say gay bill
which as you know could just as easily
be called the don't say straight bill
you combine all of this stuff and it's
like why is it
that state employees want to talk about
gender
dysphoria about gender assignment and
all of this stuff with young children
why do they want to hide it from the
parents and now why does the federal
government and some state governments
want to pay for that for children like
what really is going on here
i'm actually not totally sure i'm not
totally sure
but something is extremely wrong and we
all know it you all know it deep down
you don't need me to tell it to you
right you know it why is the federal
government interested in paying for
genital mutilation on minors who cannot
make willful decisions about their
bodies their brains have not developed
to figure out what they want or not and
even if
you took an eight-year-old who really
really felt an eight-year-old boy who
really really felt that he was a girl
it doesn't mean that transitioning him
with all of the the hormones and medical
procedures and everything else that have
to come with it will lead him to a
happier life it does not and what
happens if that eight-year-old when he's
15 realizes he didn't want to do that
are we going to start suing the
government but there is no radicalism
too radical for these people
i mean if 10 years ago you would have
said that the federal government
basically would want to pay
to transition young boys to girls or
girls to boys people would have said you
were nuts but these people will not stop
we are in
the woke dystopia of which i write we
are there
right now okay it's actually crazy
there's a canadian study by the way that
one out of five miners
who make the decision to transit
transition reverse
the decision one out of five okay
one out of five now really think about
that that's 20 so by the time they're 18
they're young they decide to do it or
the parents push them to do it or the
administrator or the school officials
teachers etc push them to do it and then
20 of them say that's not good well you
know what if your genitals are gone if
you've taken life-altering hormone
therapy for years and a whole bunch of
other stuff
you got real problems you got real
problems but it's not just sake that's
pushing this and it's not just the
lunatics in california and everything
else here's health and homeland
secretary
xavier becerra uh saying that uh he is
for it too this is a key guy in the
whole operation health and homeland
security secretary xavier becerra so for
the record you favor hhs's funding being
able for for sex reassignment
for surgeries on minors i will do
everything i can to defend any american
including children whether or not they
fit the categories you have mentioned or
not and if they talk about gender
affirming care i am there but to protect
the rights of any american
just to be clear hhs is health and human
services i think i said homeland it's
health and human services so this guy is
intimately involved in this stuff and
does that make sense to you why is the
government paying for this why is the
government pushing it why are
corporations pushing it why
i'm asking you please let us know in the
comments down below why are they
constantly doubling down on something
something ain't right but of course uh
disney is also doubling down on this
disney we've been covering this a lot
over the last couple weeks all of this
leaked video has come out that tons of
their activist employees
who mostly should probably be in mental
institutions they are telling you they
are hiding this stuff in their
programming they are intentionally going
out of their way to push this woke
ideology
and now
the disney ceo his name's bob chappic
and i didn't know much about bob chappic
before this whole fight that he got into
with ron desantis but i suspect i
suspect that bob chappic got the job as
disney ceo because he was a pretty
competent executive disney is one of the
most
powerful
corporations in the world
culturally it might be the most powerful
corporation in the world it owns all of
our dreams at this point right it owns
all of the stories it owns star wars it
owns mickey mouse it owns marvel that's
a huge problem that a giant corporation
would have that much influence over the
stories that become the lore of our
world i think it's one of the reasons
that we're so broken right now that we
don't have good stories anymore because
this because giant corporations whether
they're woke or not can't churn out good
true original stories disney is the evil
villain of a disney story in any way in
any case disney ceo bob chappie uh he
got into the fight with desantis uh he
said you know they basically summon
desantis as if he's the king and
desantis did not take any of his [ __ ]
and said no i don't care i don't care
that you have 70 000 employees here in
orlando uh i am i am the chief executive
for the people that elected me and the
and and for the people who didn't elect
me for all the citizens of florida
actually and we don't want this woke
crap in our schools and by the way a lot
of parents who take their kids to
disneyland and watch your stupid movies
don't want it either well
despite desantis trying to smack some
sense into this clown bob chappic uh
here he is groveling
pathetically
groveling at the altar of his activist
employees i pledged to be a better ally
for the lgbtq plus community
apologize for not being the ally that
you needed me to be and committed to
ensuring that our company lives up to
its values
i meant every word
and that's what we're here to talk about
today i understand that we've made
mistakes and the pain that those
mistakes have caused and i know that our
silence wasn't just about the bill in
florida but about every time an
individual or institution that should
have stood up for this community did not
i and the leadership team are determined
to use this moment as a catalyst for
more meaningful and lasting change i
want to thank the
lgbtqia plus advisory council their
allies and everyone else who has
submitted ideas on how we can take
action
that seems authentic doesn't that seem
authentic i feel like they've got
they've got mickey like standing right
behind him like
with a gun they've got like bisexual
mickey or something
but i stand i think that these people
are just horrible they're broken woke
morons and cowards that's what they all
people want to know what's the grand
conspiracy like who's pushing this why
are they all pushing it i don't know
what it's all about but i know it's a
it's a mix of of a lot of stuff right
it's a mix of woke activists and
algorithms and and crazy people who
don't know what reality is anymore and
then it's pathetic spineless people like
the disney ceo but it's not just the
disney ceo here is another member of the
lgbtp
community i've added the piece so this
is the
lgbt you know that lesbian gay bisexual
trans community i've added the piece so
it's lesbian gay bisexual trans potato
community this is cnn's brian stelter in
the united states we're seeing a theme
of the midterm elections emerging it's
the way you can see a wave start to form
far from shore before it breaks on the
beach the theme the talking point on the
right is about protecting kids from the
dangers of
the walt disney company
really
but disney is just a stem a stand-in
it's just a symbol for something bigger
a conservative backlash to growing
acceptance of gay and transgender people
as this cnn.com reporting says three
months into the new year lawmakers in
dozens of states have introduced a slew
of bills that could limit the rights of
lgbtq americans
some of those bills are framed as
parental rights bills opponents say
they're really actually anti-gay bills
and it's easy to picture this battle
continuing right through the midterm
elections but for folks who aren't
partisan warriors this battle is
incredibly disheartening
this is bigger than disney
this is a preview of a midterm election
battle
in fact it's already raging on the right
is anybody else paying attention to it
should they
so first off stealth i want to be very
clear i'll speak directly to you you're
going to be fired soon enough because no
one's watching your [ __ ] network and
you're you're an absolute joke we'll get
more to that in a second but just know
that when you're fired all you did as a
uh as a pundit or a media analyst or
whatever it is that you purport to be
all you ever did was suck up to the
power and lie and obfuscate the truth
and make everything worse and when you
are fired no one is going to subscribe
to your sub stack you'll be welcome on
locals but no one will subscribe to your
locals no you have no support all you
have is a chair which i assume is
fortified for the weight all you have is
a chair on a show on cnn on sundays a
show that existed before you and a show
that will exist after you you were
useful to the system for a certain
amount of time you potato like freak but
everything he said there was a lie or or
just a move off the truth oh it's this
is really people say it's about parental
rights but it's really about anti-gay
laws there are no anti-gay laws ron
desantis is not anti-gay i was at
thursday at an event where i brought him
on stage i introduced him to my husband
he congratulated us on having kids he
sent us onesies for the babies
if there was a move on gay rights do you
think i'd be screaming about it
god these people are liars and and
propagandists
i don't know how that happens to the
human soul i really don't i really i
don't want to just it's so easy you're
just a grifter right like that's the
easiest thing to say
are you so confused potato are you so so
confused about what is true and what is
reality why didn't he say when he says
oh but but people really say this is
about coming for lgbt rights how about
you say what the what rights are they
coming for
are they stopping gay people from being
married are they arresting gay people in
mass are they closing gay bars are they
not letting whatever no
none of it absolutely none of it
awful awful human beings um
okay
now here is brian snelter
being destroyed so i get a little
something here today so i got a little
worked up about the potato but there was
a
disinformation conference going on over
the last couple days
and here is a university of chicago
student asking brian stelter and a
couple other panelists a question about
the way these people lie about
everything and i i'm not kidding i think
i want to hire this kid like this is
just
spectacular take a look my name is
christopher phillips i'm a first year at
the college uh my questions for mr
seltzer uh
you've all spoken extensively about fox
news being a purveyor of
disinformation
but cnn is right up there with them they
pushed the russian collusion hoax they
pushed the jesse smollette hoax
they smeared justice kavanaugh as a
rapist and they also smeared nick salmon
as a white supremacist and yes they
dismissed the hunter biden laptop affair
as pure russian disinformation uh with
mainstream corporate journalists
becoming little more than
apologists and cheerleaders for the
regime is it time to finally declare
that the uh the canon of journalistic
ethics is dead or no longer operative uh
all the mistakes of the mainstream media
and cnn in particular
seem to magically all go in one
direction are we expected to believe
that this is all just some sort of
random coincidence or is there something
else behind it
it's too bad it's time for lunch
you have 30 seconds no i mean there's
there's a clock that says 30 seconds but
but i think my honest answer to you and
i'll come over and talk in more detail
after this is that i think you're
describing a different channel than the
one that i watch uh but i understand
that that is a popular right-wing
narrative about cnn i think it's
important when we talk about shared
reality and democracy
all these networks all these news
outlets have to defend democracy and
when they screw up admit it
uh but when benjamin hall the fox
correspondent was wounded in ukraine the
news crews at cnn and the new york times
stopped what they were doing and they
tried to help they tried to help them
get out of the country they tried to
find the dead crew members that's what
news outlets do that's how they actually
do work together to your question about
sharing those kinds of connections and
trust we don't talk about it enough
though we don't share that reality about
how that happens and with regards to the
regime i think you mean president biden
the last time i spoke with abidenade we
yelled at each other so that's the
reality of the news business that people
don't see that people don't hear they
imagine that it's a situation that
simply is not but i think your question
it speaks to the failure of journalism
to show our work and show the reality of
how our profession operates
we have a lot of work to do i think
i don't want to make too many fat jokes
i'm
you know
he's a large portly fella that's that's
okay
but you know his joke immediately which
is it's time for lunch what what happens
why do you joke in a situation like that
why was his immediate move to go to a
joke because the guy told the truth that
young man by the way his name is
christopher phillips and christopher
phillips if you're watching this i just
want to give you a massive shout out you
are far more of a journalist
than anyone at cnn period why have none
of those questions been directly asked
to stelter before or to acosta or tapper
or whoever else is working at that clown
network anymore i don't know nobody gets
to ask him with questions so stelter
jokes it off first about going to lunch
and that probably was what was really
weighing on him like the guy needs to
eat every couple hours obviously um but
uh it's not just that it's then his
answer had nothing to do with the
question he could have addressed the
sandman allegations he could have
addressed the kavanaugh allegations he
could have addressed any of the
allegations that were laid there and how
cnn lied about those things but he
turned it into something about ukraine
and that the the cnn staff helped the
fox staff or something that is nothing
and he kept repeating this phrase shared
reality
shared reality well i want to be very
clear if you're watching cnn and you
believe it's true or if you're a news
anchor at cnn i do not share your
reality i don't want to share your
reality you can have your reality it's
not my reality and it's not reality
reality it's a reality and it's a
made-up reality and it's a lying reality
uh i have real reality uh you watching
this you have real reality and that's
what we have to protect and defend and
as i keep saying um we have to mock the
hell out of these people let them burn
themselves down and we then have to
build new things and that really is
where most of my energy is these days
and that's what it's going to be
probably for the rest of my career in
life and purpose of this show and
everything else
that i do but the nonsense the sheer
ridiculous
give me a good adjective here well i
i always say bananas give me something
here just absurdity thank you
with your thesaurus over there the sheer
absurdity of everything going on well
now la county the place that i fled
and here's some money going into the
glee cali fund which i as i keep saying
i may be changing i was originally it
was going to pay somebody to leave
california and move to florida but
actually i think you know what i'm
officially making the change
i want i will pay someone to leave
florida if you are a lefty wingnut [ __ ]
this nikki freed or charlie crist i will
pay you to leave florida or maybe i'll
have two jars i don't know i don't want
to change it up on people people have
been emailing me that they really want
the money at the end of the year to flee
cali anyway l.a county which is the very
city that i fled uh they are now
stopping people uh
city they are stopping
city supervisors and city employees from
coming to florida on a special state
business yeah here's some info from the
dallas morning news the la county board
of supervisors voted tuesday to bar its
officials from traveling to texas and
florida after those states enacted
policies targeting lgbt youth yes that
is completely untrue actually the
pasadena star news reported that the
board vote was unanimous i'm shocked and
specifically called out
florida's legislature legislation
barring instruction on sexual orient
orientation and gender identity in
kindergarten through third grade dubbed
the don't say gay law by critics as well
as texas's recent decision to
investigate certain gender affirming
medical care for trans youth as child
abuse
i just want to be very very clear about
this as a new floridian a a proud
floridian
stay the [ __ ] away from our
state we don't want you
please stay away we don't want your
money we don't want your psychosis
stay away
don't come and then yesterday when i
heard this i was trying to come up with
a list who's left that's sane in los
angeles at this point i got three i can
come up with three right now i got uh oh
no well one isn't quite in la but close
enough i've got uh dennis prager he's
still in la they got prageru over there
and they've got obviously some sane
great people over there but out of
public people you got the dennis prager
he's still in los angeles i don't know
why you got the larry elder still in los
angeles i'm working on it people i'm
working on it and you got adam corolla
those are the big three we've got to
save them and bring them to florida
enough of this insanity and then the
fourth one that i would loosely he's not
quite in la proper uh but my buddy rick
grinnell is still in california trying
to save callie what are you doing rick i
mean what are you doing
so yes so they will not come here to
florida they will not enjoy the sunshine
they will not enjoy the freedom they
will not enjoy the beaches they will not
enjoy the smiles they will not enjoy the
iguanas
and they can stay in their dystopian
crapple but if you don't think that all
of this is enough of just the nonsense
that's going on and it's a lot of
nonsense i hope you're enjoying the show
today again it's nonsense you know it's
like it's depressing or whatever but
it's also fun in a way here here's corey
booker because you know we got this
katanji brown jackson she's getting
confirmed it's very exciting for these
people she doesn't know what a woman is
but okay fine she's just going to be on
the supreme court well corey booker in
another one of his theatrical moments
look
just finished the vote uh katanji brown
jackson has now been confirmed by the
senate to be a justice on the supreme
court
and i think there are a lot of people
who can appreciate this that
there is a lot of
hurt in this world there's a lot of
private pain and
personal
injury and
we live in a nation with
acres of ground that's been watered with
tears and sadness
but today is
a mountain of joy today is a day for
celebration today i rejoice
i
i cry tears of joy and i just want to
thank god and thank
this extraordinary woman for persevering
through all of life's challenges for
overcoming
all of life's obstacles and now rising
and knowing as when i talk to her she
knows that we
as a nation rise
rise with her
is he literally selfie videoing himself
from the closet like is he he's gay
right like isn't that a thing like he's
gay or i'm not i don't mean not to be
mean like gay is spectacular everyone's
gay now you better be gay oh my god it's
wonderful
he's just such an overly emotional
theater kid that's what he is he's a
seventh grade theater child what people
thought he was gonna be president you
clowns he's an actor he's nothing he's a
ridiculous actor but here's noted wizard
kamala harris on the excitement over
katanji brown jackson
you know there's so much about what's
happening in the world now
that is presenting some of the worst
of
this moment and human
behaviors and then we have a moment like
this
that i think reminds us that there is
still so much yet to accomplish and that
we can accomplish
okay so she just throws some words
together it's not even worth it and i do
the reason i really wanted to show that
was because of the mask thing why she's
wearing a mask she's outdoors we all
know that the masks are all [ __ ]
these people are all liars and buffoons
and frauds
all that being said kamala stay with the
mask i think you should be in a mask all
the time perhaps even one over your
whole head
that would be better that would be
better now i just want to say something
about the katandi brown jackson thing
look it as i had judge andrew napolitano
on the show last week if you if you did
not see it we talked a bit about the
confirmation hearing and his position uh
even though it was obvious that he
doesn't really love her and her judicial
positions
the judge's position was that it's the
president's right and duty obviously to
nominate a supreme court justice and
barring sort of anything like truly
crazy in their voting history or in
their decision-making history that in
essence
the senate is supposed to confirm them
that's sort of how it's supposed to work
that really is it it's the president's
decision and unless there's some red
flag that is so extraordinary that you
basically move on it now unfortunately
that's not really the way it works well
unfortunately or or fortunately that's
not really the way it works because
everything obviously has become
hyper-politicized and actually really
that all started about 30 years ago with
a guy by the name of joe biden
robert bork if you haven't heard it or
watched any of the video on that
but
this woman
she literally does not know what a woman
is she said she could not tell you what
a woman is because she's not a biologist
now relative to what's going on in the
country right now with everything i've
covered on the show today and the
endless craziness related to gender and
everything else it might be important
that a supreme court justice have some
sense of what a woman is
it might be relevant right she also says
she didn't know when natural rights
begin which might be important relative
to the fact that roe v wade will most
likely be kicked up to the supreme court
so
whether uh an unborn child is a child
when does life begin all of these things
she has apparently no opinion on any of
that uh but then we found this video and
this this is really just spectacular
here's senator ted cruz i like ted
uh he just nailed the hell out of her
and it's just spectacular sit back and
enjoy but i've never studied critical
race theory and i've never used it it
doesn't come up in the work that i do as
a judge
so so with respect i find that a curious
statement
because
um
you gave a speech in april of 2015
at the university of chicago
in which you described the job you do as
a judge
and you said sentencing is just plain
interesting because it melds together
myriad types of law criminal law and of
course constitutional law critical race
theory so you described
in a speech to a law school what you
were doing as critical race theory what
did you mean by because that was an
official responsibility of yours
what i meant by what you were doing was
critical right what i meant was that
there are a number of that that slide
does not show the entire laundry list of
different
uh academic disciplines that i said
relate to sentencing policy but none of
that relates to what i do as a judge
ted cruz
like he laid it out that was bugs money
getting wiley coyote to go right off the
cliff and then stand over nothing
oh [ __ ] like that was it right there
anyway she's going to be on the supreme
court and
so be it
it is what it is the court is
politicized obviously but again the
question is not sort of whether her
decisions lean
say liberally or conservatively
the real question related her is
does she understand what reality is and
if you don't i mean if you literally are
afraid to say what the difference
between a male and a woman is hint it
involves the uterus
then perhaps you are not quite qualified
to be making decisions on these things
that are going to be kicked to you so in
summary today before we get to the cold
close we did a little fun thing with mr
booker for you
or mrs book or whatever it is i'm not a
biologist uh
in summation we've got the border
we've got everybody turning trans we've
got critical race theory on its way to
the supreme court the left has gone full
radical show me a sane democrat
i wish there were
reinvent reincarnate
john f kennedy jr
and let's get to it show me one please
please show me one
please pretty pretty pretty please we've
got some comments from
reubenreport.locals.com
amy says every major medical association
has lost the trust of a huge portion of
the american public and saki knows it
you know that's a great point because
it's not just the american psychiatric
association and it's not just the cdc
it's seemingly everything has become
woke and politicized so it's if all of
our medical associations have and our
corporations have and our political
apparatus has we better figure out some
ways to fight against it so that you can
live a life that you want to live and i
think that that is i'm telling you guys
truly i'm telling you this uh and it's
not just because of this although i do
write a lot about this in the book on
how you can actually take a hold of your
life and succeed and thrive
that's why the subtitles not just
survive how you can thrive in the midst
of this nonsense it is happening i i
went to event two days ago here in miami
where mayor suarez spoke and you guys
know suarez i mean he basically rebuilt
the tech world here in miami because it
melted down in san francisco but he's a
republican and he gets it and he wants
to fight woke-ism and he he believes in
capitalism and miami is exploding
because of that there is a new world
being blazed right now if you're not
afraid to see it the bitcoin conference
is happening right now peter thiel gave
a huge speech about the bitcoin
conference yesterday the importance of
decentralization like the dystopian
future we were in right now it will
never lead to a utopian future because
utopia doesn't exist but it could get us
to something that'll be a little bit
more like a synthwave future with all
the cool music and a lot of the pinks
and the aquas you know what i'm talking
about a little bit purple okay uh dog
creatives says can't wait to get my book
my hubby got it for our anniversary for
me i will send you if you do not have it
doggy creative can we make a note about
this i will send you a signed book plate
and wish you and the hubby a happy
anniversary
shooky says greetings from raleigh can't
wait for your arrival at the improv
bringing my wife along and have vip
tickets you will get the one second hug
your wife will also receive the only if
you want it i'm not going to be going
out of my way to hug people if you
approach me so be it but i can't be just
grabbing people it's a lot you know what
i'm saying i'll see you in raleigh
andrew clavin from the daily wire will
be joining me there uh as you guys know
daverubin.com events if you want to join
me on tour the book comes out on tuesday
i know it's a lot of promotion i hope
you can bear with me uh next week it's
out and then we can
ease up on some of this and then i head
out on tour for a while we're we're
stacking some interviews and things uh
so that we will not leave you in the
dust on the youtube and on rumble and on
blaze tv obviously uh if you want to
join along during the shows you can go
to reubenreport.locals.com that's where
we're checking in on the live chat part
three of my interview with a same person
in hollywood rather extraordinary david
mamet director playwright really great
guy is up right now and finally we leave
you for the weekend
with cory booker once again with a
little something extra have a great
weekend everybody just finished the vote
uh
catanji brown jackson has now been
confirmed by the senate to be a justice
on the supreme court
and i think there are a lot of people
who can appreciate this that
there is a lot of
hurt in this world there's a lot of
private pain and
personal
injury and
we live in a nation with
acres of ground that's been watered with
tears and
sadness
but today is
a mountain of joy today is a day for
celebration today i rejoice
okay thanks for sharing i was brave of
you
you